If we have a stereo pair, an image that corresponds
to the left eye and an image that corresponds
to the right eye, if we can come up with a
mechanism for directing those two slightly
different images to the respective eyes, then
we have a very, very vivid sense of the three-dimensionality
of the scene and this is the underlying principle
of 3D movies, 3D television and so on.
It's something human beings have been fascinated
with for the longest time. I really love this
movie poster in this scene from a cinema back
in the 1950's. It shows us that there’s
this long term human fascination with 3D movies.
It's not a recent phenomenon. The technology
keeps changing, but the underlying principle
is exactly the same. The fundamental problem
we need to address is how do we get different
image into our left eye and our right eye?
Let’s have a look at some of the technologies
that have been developed over the years.
In order to reproduce the really vivid 3D
perception that we get in everyday life, we
need to use some rather elaborate mechanisms
to recreate that effect artificially.
So the first one is back from probably early
last century and what this device does is
takes an image which corresponds to an image
from the left eye and another image taken
from a position that corresponds to the right
eye.
Then this lens mechanism here sends the left
image into my left eye and the right image
into my right eye. So if I hold this up to
my face, I see a really vivid three-dimensional
representation of the scene that was captured
more than 100 years ago.
This is the first kind of stereoscope and
these things were really, really popular in
the early 1900s. So a slightly more modern
version of that technology is something from
the 1960s and this one has a number of stereo
image pairs on a little piece of cardboard
and a little clicker so I can move from one
picture to the other much more conveniently.
If I hold this up to my head, again, I get a very vivid 3D perception of the scene that I’m looking at.
Another approach to providing different images
into the left and right hand eyes, what’s
called the Anaglyph Technique and you look
at an anaglyph image through red and blue
glasses. What happens is that the left image
is printed in red and the right-handed image
is printed in blue and by putting on these
filtered glasses, the left image comes through
the red filter into my left eye. It does not
pass though the blue filter. So my right eye
doesn't see that. For the right-hand image,
the one that’s printed in blue, comes through
the blue filter into my right eye but not
into my left eye. So if I put this on and
look at a printed anaglyph image or an anaglyph
image on a webpage, for instance, NASA has
lots of anaglyph images of Mars, we get a
very, very vivid 3D sensation.
This is just one image from NASA’s collection
of 3D anaglyph images. The most recent Mars
Rovers all carry quite sophisticated stereovision
systems and the images are transmitted back
to Earth, processed by NASA and turned into anaglyph form and made available through their website.
What we don’t get though is a very full
representation of the colour because we’re
looking at it through red and blue glasses.
So it looks a bit monochromatic but the 3D
perception is really quite vivid. If you’ve
got access to a pair of anaglyph glasses,
these are glasses with the red and blue lenses,
you might be interested to grab them, put them
on and have a look at these next few images. They contain some very vivid three-dimensional content.
Another technique and one you see in 3D movies,
you can see Gravity or Avatar, Hobbit, something
like that, and you put on glasses like this,
what happens in the theatre is the left-hand
image is projected with light but it’s polarized
perhaps in the vertical direction and that
light goes through this filter which lets
through polarized light into my right eye
but not into my left eye because this filter
is polarized in the horizontal direction.
The right-hand image is projected with a vertical
polarization comes through this filter but
not into this filter. So when I put this on
my head in the cinema, I see a really wonderful
3D colourful representation of the scene that
was filmed.
For home use, with three-dimensional TV’s,
the technology is a little bit different.
What we use are these liquid crystal shutter
glasses. What happens now is that the television
presents the left and right images sequentially
about 100 times per second. We have left image,
right image, left image, right image and the
lenses in these glasses are synchronized with
the TV so when the left image is projected,
this lens becomes clear and the right, this
one, is opaque. So I only see the left image
in my left eye. Then 1/100th of a second later,
the right image is projected on the TV; this
lens goes black and this one goes clear. So
with these on my head, I get a very vivid,
again colourful, and three-dimensional representation
of the scene through the TV.
The final approach is to do away with trying
to use colour glasses, filtered glasses, and
shuttered glasses on my head and to project the left and right image directly into my eyes.
So in some ways it’s a high-tech analog
of the old stereoscopic viewers like this
one and this one. So here is the state-of-the-art
head-mounted display. If I put this on my
head, the left image is projected through
this lens directly into my left eye and the
right-hand image is projected through this
lens directly into my right eye.
All of the techniques that we’ve looked
at require us to wear something on our head
and that’s not always very convenient. Maybe
we don’t have the particular glasses to
hand or maybe we find that it gets in the
way of our everyday life.
So there’s been quite a bit of work in trying
to create the stereo effect without needing
to have anything on your head, so one fairly
recent innovation is the technology shown
diagrammatically here. It requires that your
head is approximately the right distance away
from the screen and there is a system of lenses
which refract the light from the left-hand
image in the general direction of your left
eye and the right-hand image is refracted
in the general direction of your right eye.